i know for a fact that i have loved this
person for a very long time and now
would not be the time to give up on him
haley bieber opens up about her love for
husband justin bieber and the moment she
decided to stick it out with him no
matter what luckily haley just accepted
me as i was the couple who got married
in 2018 had an open and honest
conversation about working through life
obstacles on the podcast in good faith
with chelsea and judah smith he's a good
kid he's a good part and
i love him particularly they addressed
haley's decision to support justin
throughout his healing from emotional
trauma which has been a journey for the
27 year old who canceled his purpose
tour in 2017 due to exhaustion and
mental health struggles
i had experienced so many things in my
life i just got to a place where i was
lonely and
i just didn't want to do it all alone
and so
i realized it was like some serious
healing i needed to
to go through in order to get to a place
where i could be in a healthy serious
relationship because i had a lot of
trauma and scars so i just committed to
working on those things and getting
healthy the singer's commitment led him
to seek treatment for depression in
february of 2019. at the time a source
told e.t that haley
knew he needed help before he sought
treatment and was a good support system
for him something justin acknowledged
during the podcast
luckily haley just accepted me as i was
even when we got married there was still
a lot of damage and hurt that i still
needed to work through but you've seen
my heart through it all as for 24 year
old haley she shared that once they got
back together in 2018 after breaking up
in 2016 she made the choice to seriously
commit i was in it i made a decision i
know for a fact that i have loved this
person for a very long time and now
would not be the time to give up on him
i just wouldn't do that to him imagine
abandoning somebody in the middle of
the worst time of their life potentially
i just i'm not that type of a person so
i was gonna stick it out no matter what
the outcome was gonna be it was really
i'm so grateful that you did
that dedication has given the biebers
the space to dream about their future
together including building a family
we've always talked about wanting to be
married and be young and have a young
family and have kids young which is
something that could potentially happen
soon hopefully
we squish out a nugget in justin's
amazon prime documentary justin bieber
our world which premiered last month he
shared his hopes for his personal life
my intention for 2021 is to continue to
set goals
and
have fun while doing them
make sure i put my family first
and hopefully
we squish out a nugget and haley wasn't
opposed to the idea but justin made it
clear that it's ultimately her decision
for now the couple is enjoying their
one-on-one time together
[Music]
for halloween the two attended a
star-studded party justin dressed as
blue the bear and haley donned a chic
black cat costume after previously
showing off her britney spears
transformations on social media
spending time together as a couple and
with their loved ones is a big priority
for the biebers it's also a sentiment
justin shared with e.t in 2015. i never
had that before you know i never had
i never created those type of
relationships so now it feels like i
have so much
like i can step into more uncomfortable
environments and then step back into
like my circle of
being so comfortable that it's it's
easier to step into those other places
whether it's interviews or you know
carpets or whatever it may be if your
core foundation isn't
supporting you then you're just gonna
you're just not gonna be balanced